of elements from Hurricane Florence and
it is pummeling the Carolina coast and
its impact will extend for hundreds of
miles the center of the storm just made
landfall in Wrightsville Beach North
Carolina florence is packing sustained
winds of 90 miles an hour it has already
jumped more than seven inches of rain in
some areas and the rainfall is likely to
set records over the next few days this
slow-moving storm and that is a problem
is expected to bring extreme devastation
due to its massive size the amount of
destruction will depend on how long
florence hangs around CBS evening news
anchor that's Jeff Glor there he is
standing in the elements leading our
coverage in Wilmington North Carolina
right now Jeff good morning hey Cale
good morning yeah we've hit the point
where it doesn't matter what you're
wearing Gortex layers upon layers
everything is just soaked down here
because this rain is just so relentless
here in Wilmington it is the wind and
the rain you know it comes in these
waves there are times when the rain is
coming in like daggers sideways and then
there are times when you might get a
little more calm relatively speaking
behind us is the Cape Fear River and
that is just a funnel of violence it has
really been moving this morning
especially when we get more of these
gusts coming through but we really are
in the middle of it right now and again
a storm Florence that is so big three
four hundred miles bigger than both of
the Carolinas combined that is not
moving quickly and as it stays here and
as it sits over the Carolinas the
biggest concern remains not the wind
we're experiencing right now this is not
a cat5 it's not a cat three it's a
category one yes there's strong winds is
it going to blow down a lot of buildings
probably not the bigger concern is the
surge for those folks especially in some
of these coastal communities and then
when you talk about that water getting
inland
into some of the larger cities as it
continues to pile up because as you all
know North Carolina and the Carolinas in
general already saturated they've
already dealt with a record rainfall
this year it's not easy for them they
don't want to deal with five or ten
inches of rain
never mind the twenty to forty
potentially that's gonna come down here
as Florence just sits in churns and
spins before eventually moving inland
but here's another big wave gust coming
in through here now again we're trying
to stay in an open area one that's clear
because the times you do deal with
projectiles in the middle of these
hurricanes will keep updating you as the
morning goes on guys back to you in New
York hey Jeff we can tell that you're
speaking pattern is different not trying
to be cute here is it because you're
just getting pummeled with the rain it's
hard it's really preventing you from
speaking the way you normally do is that
what's happening I'm trying to make sure
you can hear me good listen yeah I won't
whisper just right now Gail no I got you
I got you I got really but I will tell
you that as we move on here through the
morning Gail what to watch out for is
some of these is the tide cycles and as
the high tide comes in a little after 11
o'clock I believe this morning then that
surge is going to increase even more so
that's something for a lot of folks and
you're going to be dealing with I think
a few cycles here as the hurricane moves
through so that's certainly something to
watch out for yeah I never thought about
it guys thank you Jeff screaming and
shouting in the rain so you can be heard
while the water is coming into your
mouth that that qualifies is very
difficult normally when it rains you
hold something over your head it was
bracing as if something we're coming at
him just anticipating the gusts as well
as he described that that funnel of
violence behind him we'll get back to
Jeff in just a few moments